thanksgiving is upon us which means that
it's time for normal people to give
thanks to god for the blessings in their
life and it's time for leftists to whine
about how much they hate america
the real story of thanksgiving and some
history you probably never read in your
school books the mythology of
thanksgiving closely mirrors the
mythology of america that mythology is
the image that white americans love to
see of themselves white settlers come to
a strange land in good faith bringing
something of great value that enriches
the people who are already here the
natives also bring something of immense
value equal exchange
that closely mimics the mythology of
white america it is how america wants to
see itself
the truth of course of thanksgiving is
much different the truth is pilgrims did
not bring turkey sweet potato pie or
cranberries to thanksgiving they could
not they were broke they were broken
their hands were out they were begging
they brought nothing of value
but they got fed
they got schooled thanksgiving it makes
sense there is much for white americans
to be thankful for
but i'm still trying to figure out what
indigenous people received of value
so that history is completely wrong the
whole thing is completely wrong all the
way down to the turkeys which the
pilgrims almost certainly did bring to
thanksgiving but this guy's premise is
wrong too
actually the the msnbc host's premise is
wrong too if you're under the age of 40
you almost certainly were taught that
anti-american anti-historical nonsense
in schools in fact that was probably the
only story about thanksgiving you were
taught and it also happens to be total
bunk that history is just bs so
what
the guy in the kuji sweater says is that
the story we're told is that the native
americans and the englishmen brought
something to the table at the first
thanksgiving and it more broadly in
their in their cohabitation and they
both benefited from it and that's
totally untrue the englishman brought
nothing they didn't even bring turkeys
so yes they did you can read in governor
bradford's on plymouth plantation you
can read that even specifically on the
turkey point he sent his men a foulin
they went out they got some birds they
brought some stuff they all came
together and they ate a meal together
and that meal was representative of a
piece
and and an alliance that they formed the
englishman and the native americans
specifically one native american naza it
the guy says that the indians did not
benefit at all they didn't get anything
from the englishman that's not true
massasoit
who is an indian chieftain
was able to use the englishman to
greatly expand his power in new england
and really helped to create and
certainly to expand the wampanoag nation
he could not have done that without the
englishman in 1623 massasoit the leader
of the indian there the indian tribe
there
was on his deathbed he was dying the
englishman edward winslow out of
friendship went to go visit massasoit
mazes so it said this is all well
recorded mazes so it said edward winslow
i'll never see your face again edward
winslow made him some broth and gave him
some rudimentary medicine and sat up
with him and took care of massasoit and
massasoit recovered and then mazassowit
told the edward winslow and the
englishman about a plot from the other
massachusetts indians that were going to
massachusetts or the narragansett i
forget who were
who were making an attack he was in
massachusetts were making an attempt on
the englishman's lives and they formed
various alliances and they lived
together in in peace for a long time
actually the only reason that the peace
broke down was because massachusetts son
king philip who took an english name who
took a christian name
king philip misinterpreted the death of
his brother and thought the englishman
killed his brother even though they
didn't and so he declared war on them
and some indians sided with the
englishman and some indians sided with
king philip and the peace between the
natives and the englishmen was
irrevocably destroyed
that's the real history the kuji sweater
guy and the
airheaded msnbc lady don't know anything
about that because they don't know much
about anything at all certainly not
about history all they know about is
their ideology which which tells them
that the indians got nothing of value
what else did they get a value um
christianity that would be one thing
that they got of value i i assume that
the msnbc lady and the kuji sweater guy
don't have a great deal of respect for
christianity but they should because the
religion that the natives were
practicing it was a false religion and
it led to some very kooky practices as
as we have noted on this show before
cannibalism was fairly widespread among
certain indian tribes including
around the northeast of the united what
is now the united states there were lots
of terrible religious practices there
was enslavement all sorts of bad things
and the when the englishman came and
brought christianity to the native
americans
they they brought true religion they
brought some enlightenment to them and
they worked i'm not saying the indians
didn't give the englishman something of
value as well the englishman would have
starved without the indians in fact one
of the first acts that the englishman
committed when they got to the new world
was to find a bunch of corn that the
indians had stored and they took some of
the corn and they wanted to pay it back
later but they were starving and they
took some so i it just seems to me that
the true history is much more
interesting than the nonsense ideology
that you are in fact taught in schools
it's it's now become a canard it's a
myth to say here's the real
dirty history of america that you
weren't taught no that's all you're
taught now even when i was in school
which was now what i started school in
1995 and graduated high school in 2008
and
still even all the way back then we were
taught almost exclusively certainly by
high school
a negative history
of
the
settlers in america
and we were taught history from the
perspective of leftist polemicists who
think that colonization and settling
america was a very terrible thing
really the history that you are not
taught is the history that i just told
you i just gave you a little tiny touch
of it and what i'm not even an academic
historian i just happen to have read a
handful of books on this and so i know
significantly more
than any of these ideological lunatics
on cable news or the fellow wearing the
kuji sweater
the real history is is always much more
interesting than the fables that the
ideologues are trying to tell you hold
up i'm glad you like that clip ring the
bell
ring the bell just subscribe it's very
simple now i know even if you ring the
bell you might not get the notifications
which is why it's very important to head
on over to apple podcasts or spotify or
stitcher or google play or wherever you
listen to podcasts type in the michael
knowles show
subscribe leave a five star review we'll
see you next time
[Music]
[Music]